[Music]
thank you Robert for the nice
introduction so indeed today uh we're
going to combine DBT and Python and at
the end of um the session you'll see an
examplary running machine learning uh
pipeline where we try to beat The
Bookies and uh let's see what happens if
is it even possible maybe to gge a
little bit and to to get me to know you
a little bit who has heard or has worked
with DBT before here in this
room okay nice um quite a bit then um
that helps me a little bit so who am I
um well Robert already explained so you
can see I'm still very relevant with the
the beatroot band uh but also aside of
that you can challenge me on Lees if you
want to and um yeah let's see who wins
yeah I love games all the all day long
um so what are we going to talk about
today um very briefly first I'm going to
give a motivation on why dbtm python
could make sense for an anomalops
pipeline um then next I'll give a quick
start and um I'll even tonight you can
create your first python model in your
organization if you want
to um then we'll have a a toy data
warehouse that I created with DBT and
Python and it's using the European um
soccer um database from
kagle after which I'm going to show you
whether or not we can beat The Bookies
there are some design patterns that I'm
using in there which um I will give a
bit more context about um and to wrap it
off tonight we can eat some bitter balls
together and you can always ask me
questions as
well so um why would it make sense well
these days um or just actually every day
ever like if you wanted to um built a
reliable machine Learning System um the
actual machine learning code that would
be put into place was very minimal
compared to all the rest that comes um
alongside of
it um so first of all you need to
prepare and maintain your data you need
to do it reliably you need to make sure
that um that there's no training serving
ske then also there's all the
infrastructure that you need to care
about and all of that is being done with
different tools so Docker kubernetes a
lot of things and the data scientist
they got a lot to wrap their hand heads
off um especially in organizations what
you see a lot is like here's use case
they shove it to the data scientist
figure it out so it never breaks into
production that's a big burden to to to
have um for data scientists and that's
why it would be very convenient if they
could just continue coding in the two
languages that they love which is python
a
SQL hence DBT and python could make a
lot of sense um as DBT is U SQL first
and recently they have introduced python
models to it so that you can actually
use all of your favorite machine
learning
packages um so I I've seen that uh a lot
of people know DBT already but I'll give
um a quick um intro on what it is and
how it really helps you forward um if
you're working in a data team so in
essence it's a data transformation um
workflow
um where you work in a project and you
um basically write your entire data
transformation as being um in SQL now
what DBT already does for you it's doing
all the orchestration and um yeah you
can really see it in a nice deck as well
in the data catalog if you want um so
you don't need to worry about that you
don't need to orchestrate it um yourself
anymore um it also connects very um
seamlessly into almost all data
platforms out there um so that can be on
Prem can be relational um but also like
um on the on the cloud for example um on
gcp on AWS with red shift uh to data
bricks cluster as is what I will be
doing um later today as
well then what it also helps you do is
uh something that we all do and love and
that we try for that's um configuring
tests and writing documentation uh on
our data um so this all can you can also
reuse documentation if you want to and
you can also configure tests so that
they um break or alert you in your
pipeline then one of the main benefits
of working as a team with DBT and also
just uh the developer experience it
allows to write SQL like in a dry way um
so you don't repeat um yourself um it
does this by leveraging yja um so you
can actually programmatically write your
SQL quote um and that makes it all very
much faster as well can also reuse
functionalities by the use of Ginger
macros and a lot of these Macos are
already um available for you as
well um yeah SQL is kind of like the
common language the linga funka of uh a
lot of data experts or professionals um
so from the data analyst to the data
scientists to the data engineer they can
all work beautifully together in a
harmonious workplace uh with the
DT now uh since version 1.3 um DBT
thought like okay let's make it um let's
make our pipelines even more expressive
and to also allow you to do um things
that you weren't able just by writing um
SQL um and basically they fit in
completely in the same way so um if you
would look at the dck um it's the purple
thing there in the little deck that
would be like the python uh model so
it's so from the user point of view
there's not really much of a difference
on the back end there is a difference
but all the SQL code would automatically
um run on um on the SQL platform if
you're connected to the cloud like on
bigquery or or snowflake or data
bricks your python code will be uh
spawned to um um like yeah on the
compute cluster so your python code is
running on the compute
cluster but really using the internal Fe
of DBT um you can also make U your
machine learning pipeline now more
powerful and you can all integrate it
into one project uh really um leaving
out the the burden of having to do all
different kind of
things how does you one go about it so
this is kind of like the the template um
so in the import you can import anything
you want any package you want uh from
Sky kit learn to hugging phas um so
really allowing you that
exclusivity U as long as it's installed
on the cluster of
course then this is the main entry point
so it's um it's a function called Model
it holds two um arguments dbt1 is an
internal object that gets created at
runtime and that holds a lot of context
on uh your current uh Pipeline and your
deck so for example you can um get like
um parent models loaded in thanks to
this DBT object the session is a a spark
uh session and you'll see in the next
line so if you load in um like a a table
or a view um from in your pipeline
you're actually loading it in as a spark
data frame or P
spark uh then you do all of your
Transformations so here you do all of
your fancy
and then you return um your final
data frame and you can return it in two
ways you can either return it as a ppar
data frame or as a pandas um data frame
the schema gets inferred uh
automatically uh for you and it will
always write out um and overwrite if you
don't do anything special will overwrite
the table um into your data
platform so I see that by sending out
there like a a little bit of the
formatting changed but um that makes it
uh fun
um so the toy data warehouse is can we
beat uh The Bookies so there's actually
a very cool open- Source data sets out
there on kagle it's um it holds um the
match information of 25,000 matches on
in 11 European
countries um and it's all ordered in as
a relational database in esite
format and it also contains weekly
updates on statistic of players and
teams also the final alss that The
Bookies provided for the match before I
continue um who of you um has a lot of
experience or just a little bit of
experience with sports betting um I'll
sure that this doesn't exit the
room okay thank you not a lot so that
means I'll need to explain myself a
little bit on how ODS uh
work we have a little example here of um
of odds like um for a football match um
like um and you see the alss there like
that The Bookies provides so the home
win is 2.17 draw 3.60 3.30 what do these
ALS mean it means if I bet on the home
team winning because for example it's my
favorite team then if I win and the
event actually happens I win 1.17 Euro
that's my profit if I'm wrong uh then I
will lose € Euro if I had put one EUR in
it there's actually an implied
probability in there for The Bookies and
it just the inverse so if you divide one
by 2.17 you actually get to
46% now the interesting thing is if you
do this if you do the math then the sum
actually is bigger than 100% so why is
that well this is how the bookies make
um their
money um they actually think that the
probability is lower of these events so
they might have this and then the blue
numbers the sum is
100% if you then uh you if you then do
actually the expected value of profit
expected profit if I bet on the home
team winning you'll see it's negative
and it will be the same thing for um the
uh for the other bets as
well that also means that if if we can
have like a better version of reality on
the on the probabilities Stand The
Bookies we might be able to make some
money basically if our model is
better so um we'll try to predict the
winner given all the features that was
given in the European soccer data set I
will also like calculate some um some
features for example one that I'll take
away forner presentation is the form of
the team before the match that's like
their um their performance over the last
five
games um and then so yeah so it's
important that we model it as
probabilities and then we can transform
it to our or po as well
and then we will place our bet on the
booki and winner where our model has
lower odds or where we have like a
higher probability than their implied
probability so if you um in the same
example if the model probability would
actually be
50% um then in the view of the model
there's potential profit of um I the
expected profit if I bet on the home
team winning would be um 8.5
cents how does one architect such a
thing um first of all it's important to
like um for me like idiomatically it's
important to do as much pre-processing
as possible still still in SQL reason is
quite simple it's because like uh you
cannot beat these top SQL engines on all
the data platforms there's no sense in
trying to beat them um as well um so
yeah if it's really feasible to do just
do it and it will really automatically
um have a better performance as well
also like these kpis might be used for
something else dashboarding and so on
and they also can be understood by the
whole
team now now if I want to run uh this
part of the pipeline I can do that with
a selector a selector is a little
configuration that you put where you
really say like okay like this um this
um like yeah you just select the flow
that you want to run so here everything
up until match data sets so again
statistics um they are there also like
the the team form and then also like we
have our machine learning starting point
which is a match uh the match data
set then if you go to our machine
learning pipeline um so we again we have
two uh kind of flows um that were
defined within the selectors one is
where we run our experimentation
experimentation is a a python model and
basically what we're doing there is some
simple cross validation for example
hyperparameter tuning you train a models
and you keep your best model um as
well um then since the experiment table
it also is being snapshotted I'll
explain more about that
later um we also have the inference
itself which is a different flow um so
that would be like your daily uh flow
basically in the simulation
and important to mention here also is
like these python models um they are
installed um Al like the python code is
running on data bricks and they're using
a custom python package to have a much
cleaner
API um all of this is configurable with
um DBT project variables so you can
really design uh your runtime with
environment variables and with um
runtime variables which you just provide
in your command
line then the demo actually like the
code is also um I open sourced it
yesterday so you can take a look if you
want um like yeah I gave this
presentation somewhere else and then I
run it live but um here I don't I'm not
doing
it um so it will work the demo
luckily um and yeah we kind of need to
put ourselves back in time a little so
let's put ourselves on the 1st of
January
2016 um what's our view on the at that
Mo moment in
time um so for example I run the entire
pre-processing
pipeline um and I run it for that
particular uh run
date then the match data set would look
something like this so you see here up
until this date we have uh observed the
actual winner we have observed Target
but starting from that point of we can
make predictions potentially but um yeah
we cannot rain on it so that's
nice then we can start our
experimentation so again we have um or
designated um flows for the those so I
just did some simple models um actually
boost random forest and logistic
regression maybe um who thinks Al who
thinks that um actually boost will
win who thinks uh random Forest will
win who who thinks logistic regression
will
win interesting a lot of people don't
think um so then if we run the
experiment um so that is actually just
the results of a sky kit learn cross
validation and I can export it um
straight away um to uh the
warehouse now important to mention this
by default um it's right truncate so if
I run new experiments they will
overwrite my past experiment ments which
would be a
disaster so you take a snapshot for
example or you could make an incremental
run out of it where you go into an aend
mode also important is to always keep um
kind of like yeah um the parameters and
the runtime
variables so now I can actually U
simulate on my test set which runs from
like the 31st of July up until the 1st
of um
January and this is the
result so I have indeed um s uh for
everything I also have an expected OD
and uh I see if my expected OD is lower
than the O of the bookie I will place a
bet and I will for example leester
Manchester City I plac a bet on the draw
I expected 88 cents profit in the end I
made three uh three cents uh three EUR
on that match awesome of course I can
still lose matches
and yeah we cannot um see yet what's
happening for everything starting in
January of
course this is what happens if we
compare all of our models on this uh on
this test segments so uh yeah actually I
trained two logistic regressions because
I knew they would be the best uh
logistic regression um actually then in
the second experiment um I get to close
to 25 EUR profit on the test set which
is an average profit of 1.5 EUR
cents yeah and it's on um yeah ,600
matches that I've
predicted um but yeah now it's started
for real IC model it works up until the
end of December awesome now I can uh run
the daily or weekly pipeline like let's
imagine a weekly pipeline because the
kpis wouldn't refresh uh that often for
football matches and often play like one
game a
week so let's move ahead to the 8th of
January and see what happens if we um if
we summarize our performance um so yeah
we also see here this so this is up
until the the testing set where you see
um The Profit that we had um and then
yeah we actually made a bit more profit
on those five days that we had bets
ongoing so that's
cool and then yeah I fast forward a
little bit to the 1 of February and then
we see okay we lost a bit of money
compared to uh to
before we're still um in the
positives um yeah and everything is uh
running smoothly and I have my auto B
placed and uh I don't get that much
richer if I play it
safe so what are some design patterns
that you might have spotted and that
have used and things that I've learned
also while creating um this
Demo First is like the DPT snapshots
it's an internal feature of DBT and it's
really really
powerful um basically what it does it's
um it makes you uh manage track history
and it does this so in the type two
slowly changing
Dimension what does that mean it means
for example if we take the team form and
we look at uh the 24th of of
September um then the team form could be
12 out of 15
points if they lose the next match the
team form drops to nine um the issue is
I cannot go back to previous Point uh in
time I cannot time travel if I don't do
anything because then the first record
gets
overwritten the elegant solution is to
append an extra Row for each update and
to um invalidate uh the previous record
and DBT does this for you really
nicely um so you can just configure it
as a snapshot and uh you can select
which variables to track and so on and
also what the time stamp
is um if you apply this on um model
input you get basically the equivalent
of a feature store if you do this on the
output you have the equivalent to of a
prediction store if you do this on all
of your experiments you kind of have the
equivalence of like yeah an
experimentation framework and a model
registry so a lot of things that you
don't need additional tools
for another design pattern is the one
with surrogate Keys which is very easy
to do with the with the micro that DBT
provides to
you there's like this DBT utils
generates surate key that again look at
the team form it changes you can for
example um do like a hash on all of your
columns uh with this function and that
way you can keep track of all the
predictions you ever made and can also
avoid uh making the same prediction
twice uh the next day which is
especially handy if you have expensive
models
running then um there are still a few
limitations with respect to python
models and uh in in DBT and the biggest
one is that you cannot reuse any python
code inside of your um DBT project so
that's really like not uh not dry that's
not um don't repeat
yourself so if you still keep it inside
of your DBT project you'll have to
repeat
yourself uh also there's no Ginga uh
support however how can we byp pass this
it's by just packaging uh clean python
API yourself package it nicely and um
install it on the cluster um as I've
done here on the data bricks cluster I
had a python package called risk Rover
that was easy to use so I just had these
three Imports in my python models and uh
that's basically it and uh then it's
also still very readable what's
happening inside
DBT then what do you do with respect to
testing and documentation um like python
uh pack package you can uh inside of
that you can do your unit testing and
while the data tests those can go inside
of DBT configurations so for example you
could have um data monitoring tool in
place where uh you test basically if uh
you lost more than 100 euros over the
last year if that's the case um yeah um
go to
rehab then some other tiny tips that you
can do um that also is kind of by
experience an important one is that um
try to imagine what happens if you don't
have any outputs um because like yeah
most data platforms
they uh they work with the schema at the
start the schema gets inferred but it
might be if you run your code especially
if it's pondos code that the schema
changes um overnight and you don't want
your entire pipeline to fail because of
something like that so it's actually I
think it's good practice to predefine um
your um schema as a spark schema and you
also have an if Clause if you have empty
data return empty spark data frame with
um this
schema then you can also use um
incremental um python models so um this
is uh within the internal DBT object and
you can use this for example to um to if
you want to run an interference uh you
want to be able to run inference on all
the input but you don't want to do it on
things you've already done so in your
incremental code you can say like I'll
only make predictions for things I
haven't predicted yet with the full
refresh you can still run a prediction
on all the of the input data
ever then also we've already uh seen
this a little bit is you can really
orchestrate different and enable
different flows inside of your um
processing Deck with these selectors um
so yeah there's a syntax um for it and
that way uh for example um you can
orchestrate what has to run
when then briefly but I think it's quite
obvious for everybody here like when
should you use spark and pandas and
something in between so Spark um you use
when you're working on big data and um
you want to that that work gets um split
across the
workers uh you can it's still better
maybe to use pundles if um if you know
that okay it's a tiny bit of data it
will work as such then that's
fine if it's if you developed on a small
test set and um but you still need the
the big data functionality there since
spark 3.2 you can also um use the spark
on pandas API where they try to make it
a very seamless uh
transition um then also to also control
what running controlling the flow you
can use um environment variables and
runtime um
variables then important don't perform
too many API calls within uh your python
code uh especially in DBT reason is that
you depend on an external server there
might be an internal failure and the
entire pipeline fails so one of the
downsides of course of um moving your
pipelines your ml pipelines to DBT is
that you have this single Source um of
failure so um let's go to the quick
conclusion and the conclusion is
basically when should you write Python
and when should you write SQL inside of
your um DBT
project in general you want to use uh
the python models when um it's much
easier to develop it uh the code in
Python and it makes uh perfect sense
because that way you really reduce the
cost of development and also like the
reduce the time to develop it there's
still like a very human factor um to
this but if um if you can do it in SQL
just do it in SQL um DBT is intended
that way it's also um the more like yeah
more common tongue of um everybody in
your data
team um yeah because python is less
accessible to maybe the data analysts in
your team or the bi um
persons um one another downside of um of
python as well is like yeah there
actually the optimization of your code
really is on you while in SQL it's
already like attracted for you so that's
kind of like an other way to look at it
uh there in Python there are like 100
ways or infinite ways to do the same
thing on a SQL there's like a much
clearer path often the case
then with respect to debugging and so on
so um yeah you're really relying if
you're really relying on this single
project makes it very easy to
communicate uh within the team and to
also review code and so on and we've
seen that we can have um like full on um
melops capabilities with the with the
dbd pipeline uh DBT um pipeline now on
the other hand if your ml pipeline fails
um yeah the entire pipeline um fails as
well or like yeah especially if you have
a fail fast uh on the other hand
microservices which is more traditional
way are easier to uh
troubleshoot and that's it uh thank
you thank you so much Dorian if there
are questions please raise your hand
yeah so
y um well it's can you repeat the
question so um for somebody who um who
um hasn't worked at DBT yet that's
perspective
and um he wants to know um why he should
move to DBT because internal Ginger you
can also just write it in Python and you
can also already template your SQL as
such I think the killer feature is
really that the orchestration really
happens for you um also it's
collaboration Wise It's also much nicer
um than if you do everything um within
python it's also like SQL is more like
the common uh Tong uh for everyone so um
that way you can combine uh efforts
together um but yeah also it's one
project and your entire data
transformation pipeline um is
orchestrated tely for you you can do a
multi threading as well so for example
if you connect to data
platform um it automatically uh you can
say Okay I want to have eight parallel
threads running then DBT handles that
for you also if um yeah you're
immediately leveraging also um data
platform and you can write codes also if
you're a bit clever about it um you can
use um macros from DBT already that are
like general purpose for every database
so you can have a project initially that
that you want it to just connect to for
example to bigquery if you write the
micros like um like database
ignorantly then you can just lift and
shift to another thing for example if
big costs go out of
hand I don't know if that um like a
yeah really like your creativity to use
DBT also for specifically if you talk
data bricks and and all the developments
going into that with things like Lake
monitoring
and how does that compare in your view
how does
this should you use
this I think it depends bit on the on
the audience that you have also within
your team if you have a team with um
people that just love data science and
they have like a tiny grasp of it and
they like coding I think this is nice
because you just use pite a SQL and you
don't really need to learn anything else
it's also like the main enablers to
become a data
scientist um while if you have all these
other tools um hanging around they can
be really good uh but on the other hand
as well like yeah if imagine if you
change company and they then use a
different data platform then all that
you learned there was for nothing Well
Python and SQL they remain to
stay also makes it um what I also want
to say this makes it also easier to to
lift your machine learning models to
production um because you just have one
project for example and um it's clear
what what is expected um and if you
already have like a cscd pipeline
running to um then you run your DPT for
example from a container then if um if
you tested your code and you can just
really just um push your uh your Python
and SQL code and um you have something
that's production
ready any more
questions otherwise I have a final one
are you know a millionaire doing sports
betting or well this was in the past so
like imagine if maybe if you write
something that's scrapes all of the
bookie sites and and if you um are able
to also scrape all of the
statistics might be this is like yeah so
it's useless
yeah all right thank you so much
everyone please give a very big round of
[Applause]
[Music]
applause